hello everybody so I wanted to make a
video about walls and how walls stop
change and so because today I actually
had to come back to my house and I had
to I had to do some final cleanup
because we're gonna decontaminate today
I figured that I would just make this
video on the dike at the end of my
street so if you want to see this is the
dike at the end of my street this is not
of course the place where the dike burst
but this is the dike two days ago I
posted a video talking about how time is
devouring space and so I knew that I had
to make the video which was the opposite
or was the complement to that video and
which was about space and how space
dries up or how space extinguishes the
possibility of change and so how in a
way space crushes ah time with certain
extent and so until yeah so here we go
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
one of the reasons why it's so difficult
to understand by the way if you hear
noises it's because there's still a lot
of work happening apply Street so sorry
guys this uh this video on space is
going to be is going to be a little
bothered by it's gonna be gonna be even
a little bit by bit of chaos so the
reason reason why it's so difficult to
understand the question of the
relationship between time and space is
because what I think is is happening is
that because they're they they have to
co-exist you can't have just time and
you can't just have just space they are
interlinked in the way that they
manifest themselves it's very difficult
to talk about just one side and so as I
taught and so I decided to do it in two
videos because when I tried to see both
sides at the same time you know just
talking about one is enough to fry your
brain but talking about both is almost
impossible and that I think that's why
I've had so much difficulty
understanding it in the past because I
would always try to focus on one side
and I've seen authors that talked about
this notion of time devouring space and
others that talked about space replacing
time and I think that actually what's
happening in the modern world is both at
the same time the way to understand it
is to understand the modern world as adi
incarnation i've talked about this
before to understand it almost as heaven
and earth separating from each other and
because that happens it sends the world
into a kind of pendulum where the world
tends to swing between two opposites and
one of the opposites between which it
tends to swing is the effects of time
and the effects of space a
radicalization of both and it's almost
like a war between the two to see which
one is going to win as one you know
takes a swing than the other does as
well but today is our video to talk
about space and so that's what i'm gonna
do there's a legend that says how
Alexander the Great
at the end of his conquests up in the
more than at parts of Eastern Europe in
the Caucasian in the caucus area he
built what's called the Caspian gates
the Caspian gates were supposed to be
these huge iron gates that were built in
order to stop the gog and magog from
pouring into Europe and gog and magog
although they have been later
characterized as these kind of demonic
figures and rightfully so they were
originally seen as these nomadic tribes
that live in the on the on the steppes
in the north of europe and so the you
know what the mongols the Khazar is the
o matic tribes would actually do that
come in and would wipe out civilizations
of course one of the biggest examples is
when the mongols destroyed Baghdad um
and also when the Huns poured into
Europe you know and came all the way to
the steppes of Rome the the nomadic
tribes because they don't care about
stable space they don't care about
civilization they have this desire they
have this capacity to wipe things out
and to completely destroy things the the
Mongols would have this notion that they
would return the land back to grazing
you know would return the land back to
this stable plain you know where the
animals could graze and so it really is
this destruction of space by time it
really is the nomads the nomadic spirit
coming in and wiping out time but the
building but there's also this interplay
between the two sides and so
civilization and space pushes against
the chaos of course the dike which I'm
standing on is a great example of where
we build a dike on the side of a river
and this flowing river this this flowing
water is stopped from coming in and from
destroying and it destroying but also
renewing also restarting things because
obviously that's what happens and I'm
seeing it in my own life now that the
water has come everything is up in the
air you know it's interesting to go
through it everything is you know even
my sleep rhythms have been affected
III didn't sleep at all last night and
then yesterday the other day I was so
tired and I fell asleep so my whole
rhythm it's completely out of whack
and that's what I mean that's a cast
does that's what cast is but the notion
of space as pushing against uncertainty
as pushing against the indefinite is
something that the modern world is very
strongly about now we have to see it in
the modern world as all these systems
all these systems where there's a
strange permanence it starts of course
with the the
the possibility of writing down language
itself because language naturally exists
in its oral form where it just flows
into time and it has a more non-material
reality but as you write it down then it
starts to inhabit space it starts to
create a kind of permanence to it and
now we've seen a radicalization of that
permanence if you think a little bit
about how on the one hand I talked about
the Internet as reducing space into time
there's also on the internet a a
capacity to make permanent every single
possible thing about you the this notion
that whatever it is that you do online
is never going to go away it has it has
been completely made permanent no when
we were young we in the movies they
would talk about you know this is gonna
go on your permanent record well now
everything you do online goes on your
permanent record none of it goes away
and so that is something that you have
to that is something that we have to
consider the same in the modern world
the very notion of the nation-state is
something which is very modern the
notion of a clear border between two
states this is something that did not
exist in the ancient world rather there
was a kind of hierarchy where you know a
powerful nation let's say a powerful
Empire like Rome would have a central
city and then would have other secondary
cities and identity would flow from
these cities and then on the borders on
the margins would be intermediary places
of mixture of places of indefinite space
this kind of is kind of no-man's land
between the two between the two empires
so in the notion of the nation-state
what we have is this clear
you know razor sharp border between
States and what has happened is that all
the no-man's land all the ancient places
of indefinite space have been eliminated
the entire world has been mapped out and
everything has been delimited D
delineated and defined there is no more
you know even until the 19th century
there was this notion of the kind of you
know a dark a dark space in
in the middle of Africa but now it's all
gone all we have is a trained poet mezzo
shot-to-shot left that I review is by
design this Aaliyah
so the nation-state we have we have
eliminated all the vagaries all the
places that are undefined and we have
completely or as much as possible
stabilized space and science itself ism
is in a way to science you could say
science is there to kill all the dragons
to kill all the indefinite creatures all
the indefinite categories which exist on
the borders of reality and to categorize
everything to name everything and
therefore to map everything the notion
of the map is probably the best way of
understanding how this this space has
now gone all the way to the edge you
know there's usually a long time ago on
maps there was the there be dragons part
of the map and now we have eliminated
that there be dragons we have this sense
that there is no room for uncertainty
and it's the same with the nations as
well there is no room for change these
nation states some of them are quite
arbitrary but we have this sinking idea
that the borders of these states cannot
change they're not allowed to change and
we can't totally justify why we can't if
you think about it we can't imagine that
all these states are going to be the
same forever but we also know that that
as we have built up these very very
clear clear borders the the stakes of
the changing of these borders is very
high and is measured in war and is
measured in in in death and so as while
on the one hand we have this notion of
time which is devouring space the modern
world is also it's also at the same time
represented by a kind of radical space
where the pus where permanence this
strange permanence comes to
exist and you know your this whole idea
for example that you have these ID
identity cards that you have a name
which is inscribed in the government all
the state powers would give you you know
your your social security number all
these things which are these fix things
about you that are kind of given to you
at birth and that you that you that you
have you know forever and you and and
are impossible to change and so those
are those are the counterbalance to the
other side of the metal so I thought it
would be something that would be
interesting to think about because as I
said I really do see the modern world as
adi incarnation and i see those two
sides as ramping up against each other
and the internet is the best place to
see it what at first was the internet
was touted as being the place of freedom
the place where anything goes then in
order to counter that systems were
created for the internet to become the
very opposite the system of control that
has never been seen that the likes of
which has never been seen in the history
of the universe and so those two things
are happening at the same time this kind
of pushed towards a fluidity and anarchy
a breakdown of categories and at the
same time a radicalization of categories
and you can see it as well even as the
the identity split for example in the
whole gendered fluidity movement you see
it as well it's not just that you have
fluidity but this fluidity also creates
these strange permanent categories of
desire which are these strange
categories of of desire which are cannot
be questioned and so you have you know
56 pronouns but you cannot question them
if you question the pronouns then you
then you are in danger in some places in
the US and in New York City for example
you're in danger of being fined for
doing so and so so anyway so I'm giving
that up for you guys to think about to
think about this relationship between
space and time
to think about the relationship between
how they play up against each other in
the modern world and how they build up
one against the other and my personal
situation is the best is one of is a
great example
they built a dike at the end of my
street and at the end of our town and
they build dikes all along the waterways
of the the st. Lawrence waterway and
because of that the water has no place
to go it has no nove glands it to
inhabit and so all it can do is go up
and up and up and so at one point the
dike breaks so what are you gonna do
they'll do what this is what they're
gonna do at the end of my street they're
going to make the dike hire gonna make
the dike bigger and imagine if everybody
does that now everybody all the way up
the waterways starts to make these dikes
higher and bigger and bigger and then
what's gonna happen the water has
nowhere to go all I can do is rise rise
rise and the flood just goes up until
some other dike somewhere is going to
break and so anyway so maybe now you
understand why I'm talking about this
right now because it's a way to talk
about symbolism so once again guys I
want to thank you for all your support
and and yeah next video is going to be
about credit and how it affects our
interaction with the future so all right
guys thanks a lot bye-bye
[Music]